des immeubles encore détruit des impacts
de balles près de donetsk les stigmates
des bombardements de 2014 et 2015 sont
encore bien présents le front est à
quelques kilomètres seulement ici dans
cette région séparatiste les rues sont
souvent vides beaucoup d'habitants ont
décidé de fuir
nous sommes restés en vie par miracle
nous aurions pu mourir plusieurs fois
chacun son propre destin chacun décide
nous avons décidé de ne pas partir
non loin de là les forces armées russes
sont revenues depuis plusieurs semaines
ce massés près de la frontière pour
cette retraitée l'inquiétude grandit
chaque jour avec la montée des tensions
entre moscou et kiev la région risque de
revivre des scènes déjà vues c'est
évident les fusillades n'ont pas cessé
maintenant nous avons peur que la guerre
totale recommence
malgré la crainte de nouveaux
affrontements le choix est clair pour
ses habitants presque tous ici
soutiennent l'action russe la rancoeur
envers kiev est totale tous dénoncent
les bombardements des forces ukrainienne
il ya quelques années mais également
l'inaction des autorités ont tracé la
russie nous donne de l'argent et que
fait l'ukraine il ne donne plus de
retraite ils ont bloqué les entrées les
sorties comment pouvez vous vous y
rendre de dollars le voyage vers
l'ukraine en passant par la russie est
trop cher dieu merci la russie nous
donne nos retraites ici le rêve est
clair un rattachement rapide avec la
russie trente ans après l'indépendance
de l'ukraine de l'union soviétique